♪ ♪
>> Jesse: OLD EMAILS ARE
COMING BACK TO BITE RAIDERS
COACH JOHN GRUDEN FORCING HIM TO
CALL IT QUITS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS THE EMAILS
CAME TO LIFE IN A TOXIC
WORKPLACE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
WASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM, THE
SKINS.
THEY CAME OUT OF HIS PERSONAL
ACCOUNT WHEN HE WORKED FOR ESPN.
ACCORDING TO THE ORIGINAL POINT
BY "THE JOURNAL," ONE OF THEM
FROM 2011 SAID THIS.
SMITH HAS LIPS THE SIDES OFMICH.
HE IS BLACK.
MORE DICEY MESSAGES SENT BY JOHN
GRUDEN, EMAILS, HE CALLED ROGER
GOODELL THE F WORD AND A
CLUELESS FOOTBALL P WORD AND
SAID FISHER, THEN THE COACH OF
THE -- IN REFERENCE
TO A GAY PLAYER DRAFTED IN 2014.
SHOULD JOHN GRUDEN HAVE BEEN
FIRED?
"FOX & FRIENDS" WE CAN HOST AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
RICHARD FOWLER.
TO BEGIN, OBVIOUSLY, HE SAID
SOMETHING REALLY BAD AGAINST THE
COMMISSIONER, THE COMMISSIONER
THEN LEAKED IT TO "THE TIMES" TO
GET HIM FIRED AND MESS WITH THE
COMMISSIONER LIKE THAT THAT IS
WHAT HAPPENS.
SO RICHARD FOWLER COME UP WITH
THAT ASIDE FOR A SECOND, SHOULD
GRUDEN HAVE BEEN ASKED FOR THIS?
>> I'M HAPPY TO SEE HE RESIGNED
SO HE WASN'T ACTUALLY FIRED EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE NOT SURE HOW THAT
WENT DOWN BUT I THINK HE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN.
NOT ONLY WERE THESE EMAILS
HEINOUS BUT BEYOND THAT, THEY
SPEAK TO THE OPPOSITE OF WHO THE
RAIDERS FRANCHISE TRY TO BE.
THE RAIDERS FRANCHISE IS KNOWN
FOR BEING A TRAILBLAZER IN
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AND WHAT
MAKES THESE EMAILS EVEN MORE
UPSETTING IS THAT HE SEND THEM
TO NFL PRESIDENT, NFL TEAM
OWNERS AND OTHER NFL COACHING
STAFF.
MAYBE JOHN GRUDEN IS MORE
EMBLEMATIC OF WHAT THE NFL
LEADERSHIP LOOKS LIKE THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> Jesse: IT IS FOOTBALL, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE THINK IT IS A
PRIVATE SITUATION, I DON'T KNOW,
THERE WAS SOME BAD STUFF IN
THERE.
DO YOU THINK HE SHOULD HAVE KEPT
HIS JOB?
>> LET ME FIRST SUBMIT TO
EXACTLY WHAT HE SAID.
THESE WERE VULGAR AND SHAMEFUL
STATEMENTS JOHN GRUDEN MADE BUT
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
DIRECTLY, SHOULD HE HAVE GOTTEN
FIRED?
I HAVE TO ASK WHAT IS THE
STANDARD FOR SOMEBODY GETTING
FIRED BECAUSE ALL I CAN
ASCERTAIN IN 2021 IS YOU ARE
FIRED WHEN THE MOB REQUIRES THAT
YOU ARE FIRED AND WE ARE
INCREASINGLY ENACTING EXECUTION
AND MOB JUSTICE WITH A GREATER
SPEED GREATER PUNISHMENT.
THIS HAPPENED TEN YEARS AGO,
2011, THEY WERE ALL BY PREVIOUS
EMPLOYMENT.
NONE OF THEM WITH THE RAIDERS SO
HE'S GOING TO PAY THE PRICE WITH
HIS CURRENT JOB FOR WHAT HE DID
IN HIS PAST JOB.
WHAT'S MORE, AND I THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT, I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
IS TRULY, TRULY OUTRAGED.
ANYBODY IN THE LOCKER ROOM, NOT
ONLY HAVE THEY HURT WORSE, THEY
HAVE SAID WORSE.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COVERED SPORTS HAVE HEARD WORSE
AND SAID WORSE.
I THINK PEOPLE IN EXECUTIVE
OFFICES OF THE NFL ON
PARK AVENUE HAVE HEARD WORSE AND
SAID AS BAD.
THAT IS NOT TO EXCUSE JOHN
GRUDEN AT ALL BUT I WANT TO SAY
WHO IS MORALLY PURE TO KEEP
CASTING THESE EXECUTIONS AND
KEEP FIRING PEOPLE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
STANDARDS ARE IF WE ARE SO
MORALLY PURE.
>> Jesse: IT IS NOT A PURE
LEAGUE.
PLAYERS IN THERE, SOME OF THEM
PUT KNIVES AND PEOPLE.
SOME OF THEM ARE WIFE BEATERS,
SOME OF THEM ARE CHILD ABUSERS.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME REAL ROUGH
STUFF, PEOPLE HAVE BEEN GIVING
SECOND CHANCES IN THE NFL
BECAUSE THEY HAD TALENT.
D ANY SORT OF HYPOCRISY THERE?
>> LISTEN, I THINK THERE SHOULD
BE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY ACROSS THE BOARD
BUT IT'S WORTH POINTING OUT THAT
NOT ONLY WERE THESE EMAILS FROM
2011 BUT THERE WERE SOME FROM
2018.
IF YOU ARE A COACH OF THE TEAM,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
LEADER, THE ONE THAT SETS THE
BAR, BOTH IN YOUR LOCKER ROOM AS
WELL AS ON THE FIELD, HOW DO YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY AND AUTHORITY
TO DO THAT IF YOU'RE SENDING
EMAILS THAT ARE RACIST,
HOMOPHOBIC, EMAILS THAT ARE
DOWNRIGHT DEGRADING TO PEOPLE
WHO WORK FOR YOU?
THIS IS NOT ONLY PROBLEMATIC BUT
IT'S A LARGER PROBLEM WITH THE
LEAK.
>> Jesse: YOU TAKE PRIVATE
EMAILS FROM MANY, MANY YEARS AGO
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY GOING TO BE
TROUBLE BUT TO HIS POINT, IF HE
COMES OUT AND SAYS I'VE CHANGED
OR I APOLOGIZE, DO YOU THINK HE
CAN STILL LEAD AN NFL TEAM?
YOU THINK THESE GUYS ARE GOING
TO BE OFFENDED BY SOME OF THESE
COMMENTS ARE THEY GOING TO BE
LIKE, LET'S GO WIN ON SUNDAY?
>> I THINK SOME WILL BE OFFENDED
AND ULTIMATELY HE PROBABLY COULD
HAVE HELD THIS LOCKER ROOM AND
HAD THE RAIDERS OFF TO A GREAT
START THIS YEAR.
THAT IS BESIDE THE POINT OF HOW
WELL HE COACH IS OR HOW WELL
THEY WERE DOING.
>> Jesse: QUICKLY, WE'VE GOT
TO RUN.
>> RICHARD SAID WE NEED
ACCOUNTABILITY.
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY, I'M LOOKING FOR
POWER IN THAT IS WHY DeSHAWN
WATSON ALTHOUGH HE IS SUSPENDED
IS STILL IN THE NFL AND JOHN
GRUDEN IS NOT.
WE'RE NOT LOOKING FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Jesse